the ongoing news about rush and other
issues in it is interfering with a White
House effort to implement its agenda
president Trump goes to Cincinnati this
morning to promote his plan to improve
America's infrastructure Mary Cohn is
director of the National Planning
Council he joins us now from the White
House good morning morning charlie how
much of a threat is the focus on Russian
probe to the president's domestic agenda
including health care tax reform and
infrastructure look Charlie we're here
to implement the President's agenda the
president ran on a pro economic growth
pro-job creation agenda that's what
we're doing we're working every day to
do that and we're just going ahead with
that but clearly that sounds like a kind
of canned answer that you expected to
that question how are you going to get
it through Congress when so much
attention and so much distraction from
what's going on so look as you know you
said we're going to Cincinnati today
we're going to look at our inland
waterway system we've got 12,000 miles
of inland waterways enormous amount of
freight moves through those inland
waterways we are a huge exporter of
agricultural products to the world that
moves through the inland waterways the
Ohio River the Mississippi River we
talked on Monday about air traffic
control the privatization of air traffic
control we're doing all these things to
make American citizens lives better
we're trying to improve the quality of
life of American citizens and we're
committed to that agenda but Gary this
really clearly isn't what people are
talking about and focusing on right now
I'm curious about what the president
where his head is at right now yesterday
we heard him say he wished James Comey
luck as he testifies tomorrow is he
frustrated by what's happening it does
he plan to watch the hearings tomorrow
what is he thinking in the White House
as we go as we get ready for a very big
day tomorrow
so on tomorrow's agenda I've got the
president booked up on a bunch of
infrastructure projects we've got a
bunch of mayors and governors in
bipartisan group in talking about
infrastructure tomorrow this is
infrastructure week every day we're
working on different infrastructure
products remember infrastructure affects
every American citizen his mother's
taking their kids to school if people
going to work it's kids flying home from
college the president cares about
infrastructure he's going to be fully
engaged in a bipartisan discussion with
governors and mayor's tomorrow on it
structure will the infrastructure plan
be married to a tax measure yes or no I
don't know I don't know
so Gary if you're serious about
infrastructure why isn't there a
detailed plan we will have a detailed
plan think of what we've done already
this week we announced a privatization
of air traffic control system one of the
most important assets in the United
States we did that without a bill we
sent a recommendation to Congress both
the Senate in the house to put air
traffic control system into a private
nonprofit company that affects every
American in this country we're all
affected by the air traffic control
system there is going to be there's no
doubt you could get Democratic support
on an infrastructure plan and there's
the political support for an
infrastructure plan the question is how
the White House is operating and whether
you're doing all those steps to get
actually get something done Senator Tom
Carper is the top Democrat that you
should be working with on an
infrastructure plan
he says there's been virtually no eat
outreach at all from the White House
well look I think we're doing an
enormous effort on infrastructure we're
working it with everyone who wants to
work with us on infrastructure we had an
enormous group in the e-string on Monday
afternoon announcing air traffic control
we had support from all the participants
we had many leaders of both the Senate
and the house here we're working with
everyone that wants to work with us on
in frustrate this is important to
American citizens also what's important
to American citizen is it's what's
happening to the climate it is said that
you supported the Paris Accord although
you have no have necessary for you to
tell us how you advise the president but
has the impact of the decision to lead
Paris had an impact on the relationship
with countries in Europe look Charlie
we've got great relationships with all
of our allied nations we're continuously
working with them on many different
aspects whether it's national security
military economic we're in constant
dialogue with them we've got many of our
secretaries around the world we've got
our defense leaders around the world
we've got our intelligent leaders around
the world we're continuously having
dialogue with the world leaders the
president and many of us are going to
the g20 meetings in Germany in early
why were in continuous interaction with
our allies around the world Gary Cohn
always good to see you thank you for
joining us this morning thanks for
having me